chessmen
you're d4 player we're gonna find out
you just transpose it you recognize the
transposition side all right
I hope you have a plan B for kit you
just played it all right this is the
Petrosian what are you doing you go in
there if you go there I'll go here see
where the bush is gone now
know where your let me have it I accept
your offering what I got what I got 95 f
4 you'll be embarrassed on camera don't
do that
you know taking is right bad I get your
controller before forever so as black I
almost never guess where I'm gonna go
here to prevent a 95 nation which
sometimes happens now strategically your
Bishop wants to come here guess your
horrible Bishop right so you're not
really threatening it yet but I'm gonna
go ahead and actually you're not
threatening it I'm not even gonna stop I
guess you can go hear about another I
know what you're doing
err
okay I guess I need to control each five
now don't go I'll give you one of these
seems natural enough way you see how the
night holds back your advance you
thought I was gonna hop in there but it
almost works better on those square also
if you play Knight to d5 I can just
leave my night because my Queens running
out of this way okay you're making some
advances like not expecting just roll
over mommy checkmate
here I come wonderful who can I like
Saxon maybe yes maybe no okay so you
found some really good news however
things aren't so clear like if I go here
and give you a clock you have to write
what else you do with all this
maneuvering okay so you're getting rid
of it works bishop so it seems like
strategically i've blunder but you go
taking some stuff that's happening to
you just didn't quite happen I was sick
I don't know if I have compensation it's
gonna be close right now I can't play
here because you can throw the check in
right I have to take I was okay with
puttering past three this is a
reasonable room Oh
why do you said you can see it I'm
making my life's alright I'll make
adjustment like you better may have like
getting your dudes going to be expected
I'm gonna go this week I'd like it
haha I usually just leave stuff over
cottage
I'll just keep out of school I'm gonna
go slow going on what if I keep on
ignoring it I will go
swag on
that's where
servus pointing can bring you might
activate got that okay if I take and
take your night gets go home I'm going
to throw this in okay now I just have to
push
bear I'm going to try to trap my night
weren't you let's watch the I know
we're talking about wasting I don't want
to you to flag because you're listening
to my stupid stories that way
I was on
I look back
and then I hurried on
you can take the nine if you want I
don't know what's gonna happen if I play
up free either getting made it or you're
not
that much is please you don't want to
get me
so can I meet you in the h5 you're
running out of squares right you're
going to go there
one time the one thing what that's fair
all right
I should just make a chestnut after
maybe maybe this was made all along
studios are some kind of mate
right right right you're kind of almost
stuck aren't you
so I'll just make a chess move
trust me see even if you played clean f2
I would have just left my queen there
because the Queen trade doesn't let you
out of the box
let me do it what a guy I will chalk up
half of my wind to the fact that I was
talking through every one of your
minutes you're a good player yeah so
sometimes I can sack up on for long-term
compensation even though you got rid of
your worst minor piece just because you
got nothing going on this time of the
jets port probably that was not quite
sound but in a blitz game the initiative
is worth that little half pawn advantage
or so alright my friend good one
you